only
this it's so
simple what else could there
be but just
this
just whatever
is whatever is apparently
happening whatever is
apparently
appearing
that is
[Music]
fulfillment that is what's longed
for what's longed for is
inescapable can't not be what's longed
for
always what's longed
for just
this is what's longed
for this apparent
day or
night this apparent
body this apparent
world it's all unconditional love
worlding
bodying daying
nighting
breathing
speaking hearing
watching eating
laughing listening to
music it's
only
this
it's impossible to
escape it's impossible to not be
this it's ridiculously easy and
ordinary
whatever
is apparently
happening that's what's longed
for that's
fulfillment apparently AR
Rising
nothing
everything is this sing it's always
fulfillment it's always
beloved it's always
already wholeness
it's always already without
me it's without Center
points simply this has no location has
no
identity has no
name can't be objectified or contained
it's just always already
this hi live
chat thanks for tuning
in comment in the chat this is blind
fulfillment m
yes
yes what's always longed
for is always already
this it's
inescapable the B
body seeking which is completely
futile always ends
up as the no thing that it always
was it never moved it never went
anywhere
yes it's just what's
appearing including all of the apparent
change the body appears to
age the day appears to change the
night the night appears to change the
day the technology appears to get
better
smaller more higher quality
there's an appearance of decentralized
autonomous organizations building
new basic needs
infrastructures which is so
exciting bodies being
free
of
selling apparent time for apparent money
to pay for basic
needs and then what
play unbounded
play Joy Freedom
Prosperity unprecedented
unparalleled
waking up every
day and joyfully
playing building
[Music]
Community having basic needs be
met and just being the unconditional
love that always
is all the
bodies Joy
yeah the
laughter the
comedy
yeah these basic needs being fulfilled
and bodies being free is yeah Sports
it's music it's Play It's comedy it's
all kinds of
Joy the joy of
children that are innocent and
without
bounds
this can't be
known this is not an
attainment it's not an object to
collect and know and
share
what already is can't be
attained what already is is
unknowing the
freedom
of
Unknowing and of
ceasing the compulsion of me to know
this this can't be
known that's
freedom
it's good to see the live chat and
Community let let's
go
me which is
always
nothing apparently
[Music]
meing can't help but try to know
this can't help but try
[Music]
to
collect Concepts and ideas and objectify
this into a mirage like
register there is no
register and there's no conceptual
filing
system it's just
this it's it's always already nothing
everything it's always already
that and it's not
knowable it's not an attainment because
it's what's always
already
when me apparently unwinds and dissolves
it is seen that it never was there was
always an already only
wholeness there was always already only
this and that wholeness
only that simply
this
is the change
that the world
needs because from that place of
wholeness
only of
non-locality which is always the
case from there
dawing creating decentralized autonomous
organizations of basic needs
infrastructures is effortless it's
spontaneous it's playful it's joyous
it's no longer about an elusory center
point it is seen that there never
was the center
point the center point trying to get for
itself was always an
illusion
yes nothing to
find nothing's ever
lost no one to
see
yes
no doer
controller Center
Point just pure natural
spontaneous bouncy joyful
play Freedom unconditional
love it's non-local
everying it's incredible
it's
awesome and it's also very
ordinary it's what always
is it's what always
is yeah dawing is such a
fun way to say
it
it's so beautiful
how the da of thousands of apparent
years ago is now a decentralized
autonomous organization in the web 3
evolution of the internet which is not
owned by
anyone it's indescribably
perfect
there is no
crisis but
apparently me is undergoing a
crisis which is an inability to find
fulfillment in
objectification
unable to find fulfillment in a world of
others unable to find fulfillment in a
world of nation
states unable to find fulfillment in a
world of personal
love no matter where it travels no
matter what books it reads no matter
what experiences is it
has it seems to be unable to find
fulfillment to find wholeness that it is
already and even that whole story is
just
this
it's only
this when
me in all of those futile
efforts is
absent which is always the
case then
dawing which has nothing to do do with
what a Center Point can get out of
it is effortless natural
spontaneous there is already no Center
Point
therefore there is nothing that the
center point can get out of
this there's just
this only
this if that's appearing as clear
non-locality that's
Ving if it's appearing as an apparent
me that lacks and
seeks that's equally this
[Music]
in so there's no difference
between nothing
everything and an apparent something
lacking there no
difference
and it may arise that there's
a that something that's
apparently lacking may ask a
question which is again just nothing
asking a question and there may be a
spontaneous body response which is that
there is already no you and there is
only
non-locality and that's already
unconditional love every everything
thinging and there may be an
apparent
unwinding or decontracting
into what always
was that's all just the story and that's
all just
this
comment in the live chat yeah seeking
sucks yeah seeking is
suffering seeking is
suffering because it's the illusion that
this is not
already it's the illusion that this can
be
found that nothing everything is an
attainment
it's
not it's always already unknowing it's
always
already yes there's no to hold on
to that's
freedom
no to hold on
to
ungraspable no
ground no
shelf for anything to sit on or rest
on
a surreal
boundlessness that always
is
yes compassion love arises without a
need for ownership
when there's no Center Point there's no
owner the unconditional love is
non-locality it's
everything a Center Point can only be
personal
love it can only be
locality
it's a it's like a
solidity in what is obviously not
solid yes it's
helpless
yes no
hope no
fear
yes yes woo
yes
mhm this is death to the
seeker
yes and it's beautiful because it's
always been
death
it's always death
living it's
always death
ising it's always
that there's no Duality between life and
death it's just conceptual
masturbation
it's just
this
only
this this
sing yes
this
sing this
sing there's a comment
about Wishful thoughts holding hands and
frolicking through fields of wild
flowers won't prevent further
enslavement
that's
exactly how me
thinks me projects that there is
another there is a they that is
enslaving and that me must
do what it believes is right or good and
it must eliminate what is bad or
wrong me lives in a world of duality of
others and
they and right and wrong good and
bad and in doing so it misses the
unconditional love that everything is
and it
also builds or creates from a center
point from a place of lack from a place
of trying to defeat others or
they it also tries to get validation or
worthiness for itself look at how big of
a champion I
am
so the only
way to be the change that the world
needs which has been discussed on
several episodes now is through the
absence of me which is always the case
so from
hessing from
non-locality everything that is created
is therefore unconditional
love it's very simple it's so
simple and it's not something that me
can know and and it's not something that
me can put into a
box and it's it
doesn't me is in
too tight of a circle of a stinky Little
Pond of its own conceptual
knowing and it's too tightly gripped on
on an idea of there
being others and they and
enslavement in its own dualities of
right wrong good bad it's too tight of a
cloud of
knowing but that whole thing is made of
nothing that whole thing is made of
non-locality that whole thing is made of
wholeness so me spinning in that tight
Loop fighting other Miis spinning in
tight
Loops is absolutely
futile that's the definition of
separation
porn which we'll do a whole episode
about
soon
and that is actually made of
wholeness it's no thing appearing as
tight Loops of me that are projecting
that that's another that is bad and the
another one saying that that's other
that is
bad
yeah conceptual masturbation appears
quite a lot mhm it definitely seems
to oh
boy especially here in
Austin
Texas there was a a moving here of this
body
and it seems to have been around
dawing building basic needs
infrastructures and and also
around chopping off
heads there is a lot of new age
conceptual
masturbation a lot of Center points that
are on transformative spiritual
Journeys
and there's a a calling in a way of this
colie energy to cut
Duality and to cut the ucer
me on its journey to
wholeness so it's exciting stuff being
here and it's already showing up quite a
bit this conceptual
masturbation it's uh me that is in a
knowing Cloud that is speaking to get
validation from another me that is in a
knowing cloud and it's just masturbation
of validating conceptual
knowing it's
fascinating
and there have already been several of
those
cuts and it's been fascinating sort of
watching that
wobbling because me is trying to
manipulate the appearance control it by
bringing no thing into its knowing cloud
and no thing is just
cut
it's
beautiful yes the drive of me is for
something
else I will Attain
I am
real I will be worthy when I have shared
my conceptual knowing and it has been
validated and I am padded on the
back good boy good girl good conceptual
knowing good
job
completely
futile it's this appearing as me seeking
validation it's no appearing as that and
it's beautiful and perfect and whole and
free it doesn't need to be
changed
the bodies movement
to out of need to
change
is
black it is what's apparently happening
is not perfect and it needs to change
and it's so beautiful because absence of
me which is always the
case
it's it's so
naturally
just unconditional
love and it's also natural Al building
Dowing basic needing for the
whole as the
whole
yeah there's nothing
else nothing else
baby it's
[Music]
this never lost never
found simple ordinary
only
this
a
wholeness
[Music]
Freedom it's always
already
what's up
[Music]
alpacas
and here's number
three there's three of them
here
[Music]
yeah
comment about happy to be here
yeah happy to be
here
yeah happy for this
sing the Perfection of this thing that
is never
left
so perfect so
free requires a dance
potty so perfect so free yeah so perfect
so
free yeah yeah yeah yeah so perfect so
free yeah yeah yeah so perfect so free
yeah yeah yeah only this just this
simply this so perfect and
free all right maybe we'll do a little
bit of
a play a little
bit so perfect so free the dance party
so perfect so free the dance party yeah
yeah so perfect so free the dance party
simply this only this just this so
perfect so free the dance party so
perfect so free the dance party H so
perfect so free the dance party what
what so perfect so free the dance party
that always already is perfect and free
always already is perfect and free what
what always already is perfect and free
always already is perfect and free
always already is perfect and free not
an attainment can't you see always
already perfect and free so simple so
ordinary so simple and
ordinary so simple ordinary and
naturally free
spontaneously free
ha perfect and free dance body
uhuh fun
jams
it's just so
perfect
yeah looking for something other than
this is
missing the perfect thissing that is
always
here that always
everywhere it's actually not possible to
miss because even looking for something
else is still the perfect
thissing but me is
that that endless pursuit of something
that's not
this the endless dissatisfied pursuit of
something that's not
this
I will find it books gurus experiences
substances relationships travels
material possessions I will find it I
will attain
[Music]
it brick wall brick wall brick wall
slapped slapped slapped
slapped oh
everything's all
ready yes it's already no thing
everything so simple and
ordinary
comment in the chat this is never known
yes the freedom of this never being
known
yummy yum yum yum
y the freedom of
Unknowing always already unknowing and
free yeah yeah always already unknowing
and free always already unknowing and
free what
what OBS says there has been a
25% dropping of frames this episode
which is very
high I'm curious uh how it comes
out how it's coming out
now haven't had this issue with the
internet yet
here
[Music]
there's been
some solar
Punk
inspired
visualization of the
a
dawing that we can share and play on for
[Music]
bit free energ
energy free water free food Free Shelter
free
energy free
well-being just perfect
freedom
m
[Music]
endless oases
homeow
website joining
the the
owners the
Developers
[Music]
deepen is the decentralized physical
infrastructure
Network
first ever Dow backing are tokens with
hard assets that produce clean energy
water food and housing who let's
[Music]
go the light paper is really good too I
would recommend taking a look at this
it's quite robust it's describes the
tokenomics and the mechanism very
beautifully something that's been worked
on for quite a while by the developer
[Music]
team
it's right there on the
[Music]
website this visual is really good we
worked on this
one trying to simplify what's
happening the current fiat
currency has no
decentralization nor
backing just like Bitcoin has
decentralization but doesn't have
backing not backed by
anything and
here the backing is with the basic needs
assets of humanity with massive life
[Music]
impact
the interface itself for
how the da is built and
developed
is burgeoning so
beautifully getting easier and
easier to Homestead with the da to
develop with the
da to earn tokens that are backed by
real world infrastructure
structure I'll likely do an
entire stream on the light
paper and break it
down answer any
questions perhaps Inspire some more
develop ERS to
join most Dows obviously don't have lots
and lots of projects whereas this Dow
home da already
has hundreds of millions of dollars in
projects it's transitioning to new
energy
infrastructure
really beautiful app too
that's the interface and the
tokenomics the
[Music]
visualization
so yeah this is a very very fun way to
get
inspired
yeah it's a pretty good way to visualize
it
actually there's just so
much
demand it's
beautiful but the Demand right now is
being fulfilled
by
just copy and
paste
developers and there's really no
incentive
to
begin this
sing and so homeow is this big incentive
to begin this in so the future of Austin
the future of us especially in this
southern area that's growing so much in
its population because of the nice
weather and vast
Lands new Poss possibilities New
Frontiers and
then the different areas around the
world that are also modernizing
technologizing being focused on this
type
of envisioning of
what development can look like and
having the actual longterm vision and
incentive structures in place for the
decentralization of basic needs needs
and for this type of harmony with Earth
and one
another it's so
simple it really
is all of the Dynamics of Separation are
what's
complex this is really
simple
[Music]
yeah fun
stuff
[Music]
always already only this
thing simple
thissing ordinary very
[Music]
ising
okie
dokie we'll wrap up this
episode will'll likely be back on
later
[Music]
m always so simple isn't it sweet
Arts it really
is